all right welcome back to the show if
there is a college basketball season
from start to finish throw in march
madness john treats telling us tonight
well the rebels might want to prepare
for that dance party just in case
t-minus 20 days until the running rebels
return
there's going to be so many things that
are thrown at us this season you know
guys might get sick certain things so
you know just pairing myself mentally
marvin coleman is now closer to being
local legend than local walk-on
the loose ball diving triple-double
thriving los vegan
is now a leader but he hasn't changed
sticking to what i've done you know
since i've been
five years old playing basketball and
you know hopefully i've reaped the
benefits of that so i'm going to
continue to do everything i have done
unlv has graduated from perpetual
rebuilding project to legitimate
conference contender
three starters return and two big time
transfers are eligible in david jenkins
and caleb grill
david he's a phenomenal player you know
he averaged
20 plus two years in a row so you know
obviously people are going to be
expecting a lot out of him
caleb transferred from iowa state that's
big you know that's big time we have two
two veteran players to add with along
with myself bryce baquet
and we got a group of young guys coming
in this week marvin also got to be the
point guard for democracy
when i went i was in i was in line for
an hour and 30 minutes
so you know it was kind of cool you know
i was telling my teammates i was people
watching you know trying to guess like
oh i wonder who this guy's voting for
the foothill high grad is a human
services major
he is trying to be a bright light for a
city trying to heal
especially with things going on the las
vegas strip and stuff like that you know
as a las vegas native that kind of hurts
seeing that and seeing the
hotels shut down it actually gives me
some hope you know seeing
stuff open back up you know us being
able to play i feel like
you know sports coming back around is
giving you know the world just something
to look look forward to in a way
john treach hates sports now